Rule number 11,
do not bother children when they are
skateboarding.
That's a very specific one.
Yeah,
it is.
Well,
that's a,
that's an essay about masculinity
mostly.
You know,
I used to watch kids skateboard on St
George Street,
which is kind of cool because obviously
St George is the dragon slayer.
That's the street I work on,
which I think is quite funny.
And anyways,
these kids used to,
you know,
they're teenagers,
young teenagers.
We had these long bar hand railings
going down some shallow stairs,
but a fairly good flight to them and
they would board slide down these
rentals.
It's crazy.
It's,
it's concrete that's pebbled.
It's like you don't want to land on.
You probably heard a lot of bones
crunching over the years watching them.
It's like,
you know,
but they didn't have much protective
gear on and you know,
and eventually the university put up
things to stop them from doing this,
which I complained about in this chapter
for a bunch of reasons.
But like I liked watching those kids.
I like watching skateboarders do those
crazy things because they're trying to
become competent.
Like in there they're facing danger.
They don't want the damn protective
gear,
like sometimes it's just stupidity.
It's like where a damn helmet,
you know,
but sometimes it's not.
It's like,
no,
I don't want to wear a helmet.
I want to expose myself to this danger.
It's not that I'm stupid.
Maybe it is,
you know,
I'm just being careless,
but maybe it's not.
It's like,
no,
I'm facing the danger.
I'm trying to master it.
And if you watch kids board slide down
like handrails.
If you don't think that that's
courageous than your.
And maybe stupid.
Those two things aren't so easy to
distinguish,
but it's brave and when they do it,
it's like amazing.
It's,
it's impossible to do that.
You jump in the air,
you grab your skateboard,
you balance on this stupid rail,
you slide for 20 feet and the,
you know,
the price for failure as well.
You do the splits on the rail.
That's not fun.
You know,
or you landed
the first one that can change your
masculinity.
Masculinity like that.
Yeah.
And so like,
and the kids are often shooed away.
It's like,
wait a sec there.
They're practicing being courageous.
They're practicing mastering something
in the face of danger,
you know,
and a lot of the rebellious behavior of
young men in particular,
which is very frowned upon in the
schools.
It's like that's toxic masculinity.
You know,
that horrid,
horrid phrase.
It's like,
leave those damn kids alone.
Let them like.
Another thing I referred to in that
chapter is about 10 years ago in
Toronto,
they changed the insurance rules
governing the playgrounds and parents
had raised money for these damn
playground,
so there's nothing wrong with them.
They took them all out the whole city,
like two weeks before school started.
There was nothing but dirt and gravel.
What happens to her and rubber enough or
they weren't bouncy enough,
they were too unsafe.
Who knows?
Swap.
There was nothing wrong with them.
Well then the kids were.
I saw the kids on top of the school
because they needed some danger.
We know that kids on playground
equipment,
they will push to the limit of their
ability.
That's what you see what you like.
When you go see a sport like gymnastics,
know what you think.
Go see a gymnast and like the gymnast
does a flawless routine and like
everybody claps like Matt and you know,
the judges say nine point nine and it's,
it's,
and then the next person comes up and
they're screwed.
It's like nine point nine was basically
perfect.
How can you do better than perfect?
And then they do it and,
and,
and you can do better than perfect
because.
So the person is like,
they're on the edge and they go out
there and you know,
you watch them,
you feel it in your body because you're
mimicking them physiologically.
You see that everything they do is that
much farther out into chaos than
anything they've ever done.
Right?
They're pushing themselves to the
absolute limit of their ability.
And everyone's like this because you
tell with every gesture that they're
that close to making a mistake.
And so they've taken this courageous
step beyond their competence and put
everything on the line and that
celebrate in that.
And then when they land,
they land in a way that's unlike
perfect.
It's perfect.
Plus.
And everybody immediately leapt to their
feet and like they get a chill right and
it's the same chill.
Your hair stands on end.
It's the same cil that a mouse has when
it looks at a wolf the most puffs up.
It's all.
And so what you've just seen is all
inspiring because you've seen someone
courageously move past perfection into
the unknown and,
and not only knowable themselves more,
but to ennoble humanity itself.
And our partner your feet.
It's like,
yes.
And then it's tens,
right?
It's tens,
they win the gold and it's like,
well everyone knows what that's like.
It's like a great musical performance
and that's,
that's been in that place where
everything lines up better than perfect.